hello beautiful people give me one in chat you can hear me how is it going
amazing today we have a lot of topic to go through a little bit of live charting here is luca
let me check if i can share screen to you
let's go directly in action
can you see my screen guys
nobody says already made 100 points in nasdaq amazing what's happening here what do you see
from this auction the opening
we see an absorption amazing long you took luca amazing long there was a small long from here
there was a small long from here i don't know if it's visible i loaded five contract here
and reloaded here took out here i did market opening scalp amazing one and we are now in a consolidation
phase the reason i decided to take it out is because i see this absorption it is super strong
and i see this lock in of the sellers okay so now i have a condition where the sellers are pushing
even if we are we are in um an uptrend okay up direction so we have two gameplay for today we have
the breakout and test of this level but they need to accept it okay i know that i wanted to do theory
but it's immediately presenting a setup no it's not bad there it's bad the quality i'm streaming full hd guys
i can see clearly is it better the quality of the video i think it's good
quality is good okay now as you can see the buyers are trying to get aggressive on this level so it can be a
situation where we can load some risk on the way up and try to have an extension on this squeeze
that we can have here okay now we have multiple setup anticipation of the squeeze
and uh trapped sellers as you can see these sellers are not rewarded i see people already making money
wakas fabio i made nine thousand dollars yesterday my best day i've ever thank you for
this session thank you guys it's beautiful to see look here look here look here look here look here
okay this is something that we can capitalize on this is something that we can capitalize on they
already locked the aggression now let's see if they can hold it or if it's an absorption the direction for
the day seems long guys already from the opening now i'm watching the chart i feel good now arslan
i feel good ready to go ready to go now we want to see how it follow through on this one
let's see how it goes
no now i'm trading so it's low size because i don't feel really good guys so i took uh only 10 contract long
that for a lot of people it's enough money and uh only made the six thousand i don't even remember
yeah five thousand and eight hundred nothing incredible but still uh ah there is one guy that
told me that it's a demo account so i just want to show you something okay this is my account that we
have here and as you can see i just want to show you that
it's directly connected just to show you i don't want to open a position okay when you open here you
get the feel in interactive so it's directly reflected here it's not a demo account it's a
real account i only trade the real account okay
now what happened here we can see that the buyers broke out this level and we have a sellers that caught
absorbed now they are reloading okay now they are reloading so it can have sense okay that all this
stack of sellers get tested back okay so we have a deep retracement on this one that's the reason this
one for me it's a really stupid trade i just wanted to show you that it's connected let's close this as
soon as possible and we have a potential test of the single level okay we got we got filled just
demonstration purpose guys it's not a financial consultants and stuff and it's only for educational
purpose now they test this level they are not loading back this one so one trade that you can have
is the deep retracement here okay and we want to understand where we can have a deep retracement
lag andrea says doesn't seems lagging to me guys it's only andrea experiencing lag because i have an
amazing connection guys it's really stable
now can you see what's happening here we have an absorption a huge up can you see this absorption guys
it's enough the quality of the video to see this small line okay so this one is the most important
level that we have now because we have a huge also at the top we have absorption of the sellers but
here i think it can be the reload point let me draft the area for you okay this can be a reload point of
the buyers okay okay this can be a real point of the buyers where they continue to to go up from this move
let's see how they behave let's see also the target that we can have so
the profile framing as you saw yesterday is long and also today it's long
the first sensitive level that we can have is the round 26 100 this is a level that can become a target
of today of this explosion and this is another one to three risk to reward that you can take as you
can see the market is getting absorbed is continuing to get absorbed okay is the closest round number is
the 26 1000 100 sorry then you have the 26 200 this is levels where they put options
so it's level that where you usually see a little bit of rejection
this is price discovery yeah because we don't have price action of the morning here so this is new
level and price discovery we can also mark the previous
level of protection of the sellers that it's where the sellers try to capitalize on and they got
completely absorbed i pick same take profit level based off cash session i in previous weeks amazing
amazing guys i know it's only i know it's only one week that we are making lives and we already
flooded the platform with incredible value but how many of you how many of you are having results with
these methods one in chat how many of you are making money even if you are just starting the chat is crazy
so the the method it's easy guys the method it's easy okay it's not difficult now um ricky i think
asked when we can we open a trade so in this situation ricky they are deciding okay so you see
the ups the previous absorption okay this will be my premium level this will be a level where i'm interested
you can see that the sellers are getting absorbed on this horizontal level but they are still pushing
okay so the levels that i would consider here it's this absorption level if we get a break so you have
either the squeeze okay that can be an easy one to two risk to reward okay or we can wait for deep
retracement okay and we can have a proper high risk to reward trade this is based on your decision let's
see how it behaves so first of all we want to see the breakout of this level okay you remember the
setup that we took the other time where there is absorption from the sellers okay then there is
aggressive buyers and we capitalize on the runner
i will show you something i will show you something i think we can go here guys i think we can go here
just wait for the market to get deep discounts
i have a question for the profile framing we go later to the profile framing now we are just charting
what can you notice in this area you know what you do in this case
what you do in this case to understand what's happening we go on the cvd the cvd is the proxy of the
pressure you see all these sellers in all this area they are pushing they are making a lower low
so what do you see from price there is a follow-up or there is an absorption
is this being follow-up or the sellers are being completely crushed here
the sellers are being crushed here okay so what does it mean
this level it's a reload level okay so probably we will not go here anymore
target target we see it's here it's a big risk to reward trade let's see how it behave we have a floor
this is the protection floor i can think also about scalping a little bit guys this is not
a difficult trade
look how much is beautiful
look how much is beautiful okay they broke this range and now they are fighting against
against the top range sellers okay you know what's funny that when you long here
here at the breakout okay when you long here you have a protection point that it's on this level
for the break even so it's really close so you go risk free pretty fast and then you have a run up
that is one two three point eleven okay they just tested the level let's see how they behave
see how they behave
this is our feeling
now i cannot manage position and also watch the chat but this is something nice
no i didn't took position
didn't took position i'm replying to your question
for me the big trades it's easier
for me the big trades it's easier yes they can still go they can still go in the retracement
okay they can still go in the retracement but till this level hold
till this level hold we have we have a long bias for the day they can still go in the retracement and
we can have a second shot if we take a stop loss here we can try a next one so it's it's not a big deal
i don't know why it's bringing this level around let's remove it okay let's observe how they do now
they are loading on the top range as you can see here on this area and you can see the interaction
so this was the interaction of the sellers here we don't have participation of aggression but you can
see this attempt to break that failed at the same time the attempt of the buyers failed so we are
in a balanced situation if we go in the profile okay and we mark here we can see that sellers are
protecting from here this is the top range so this is where also if we break we expect a squeeze see
this as the acceleration level and then we have a huge absorption of sellers at this cluster
so to refine additionally the area this is what's happening summarize for you all
yeah the risk to reward is the same okay you see what happens they reloaded exactly from the level i
told you now when they approach this level all these sellers are forced to close and this is what i call
squeeze okay this is what i call squeeze because when they accept and the candle close here all the
sellers will not hold the position when they are proved wrong when they are proved wrong okay so you
see this sudden movement and then you need to understand if there can be a follow-up or not in
this case they fail the auction the buyers okay they fail the auction so what you can do you can either
decide okay if i test this trade and i i test this level and i reject again i can go to zero for
example here you go risk free we had a really close risk free level you go risk free you don't want to
put risk in the market okay so you have the risk free on this white level guys i'm taking you by the
hand explaining all my mental process okay it doesn't get easier than this and remember that break even
it's a free attempt so you don't risk anything day one for vivek amazing
they are pushing back to the break even level
and they push to the break even okay so they took us out but look what happened can you understand what
we did now we use going to break even in a smart way we removed the risk from the market so fast how
many of you without this method would have taken a stop loss this is the best management method you
can apply okay because you save stop loss and if you can if you can transform a stop loss in a take
profit okay in a zero risk look what what the market is doing why and now you understand why my
break even point was so close because if i have a failed deduction here they will go back here
it's a logic okay if the buyers cannot push hard they will go to seek passive orders liquidity below
this level with a with a big probability okay so now all these buyers early buyers will be run through
okay look what the market is doing bam okay you will have lost money on this one
because it's so important to have a guide in the position management
failed auction guys it's when they attempt to buy so you have big trades on the top but the price
section don't follow okay the position don't follow where they are going to the area that we marked in
the beginning they are going here guys let's be patient and let's see so this one break even
you can see what happened in the opening we had an absorption of the sellers a huge aggression
an absorption of the set so this level is really interactive and what they are telling you from
the big trades they are telling you from the big trades look either we are interested in this top
range or in the bottom range in the middle how much activity of the big trades you have
how much activity of the big zero
exactly first you said we buy at the top but they didn't broke
if this break with a full candle you have not only the setup from here you have also the setup of
break and test it's a one to two inside here it's i call it the dead zone there is no interest there is
nothing to do and there is no way to risk money okay so look at this level okay 26 000 051
what is this telling you what is this week telling you
this tell you that when the seller step in to continue the move lower even if we are not in the
area the buyers absorb this pressure and i think we can clearly see can you see this is striking the
bottom with this cell candle but the result is by what does it mean that we add an absorption and now
look at the cbd the sellers reload okay and we go to our area now from here
be really careful at the interaction oh what you see
what you see here you see the interest as i told you they are engaging at the top range and at the bottom
range now the sellers are engaging at the bottom range what does it mean that they expect that we
can break all this area okay now the battle is happening okay we have passive order absorbing and
aggressive order responding here okay aggressive order responding this is where we frame our setup
what's the method of execution you can have on this one okay if you are really aggressive you can
consider a first test limit if you are a little bit more conservative you can consider the acceptance and
breakout of this level okay this is not a failed auction because they didn't engage the law
they just got absorbed guys this is failed auction is when you attempt to break an eye or a low and you
fail this one is the first touch and it's absorbed okay now this level becomes the decision
okay if they break the origin of the move of these aggressive sellers they won't go long and how much
space you have to go long this it's enough to be worth and to cover the risk that we put in the
position back considering that the risk it's this one is it worth guys from a risk to reward perspective yes
or no it's worth it okay it's more than one to two yes way more probably it's one to 2.5 one three
okay and you can also trail your stop loss huh now let's see if they manage to break
ah again why it's powerful because the break-even point is here so it's really close the break-even
point where we we take out risk from the market guys before making money you need to learn
how to not let the market take your money back okay now this is one minute it's not range it's not range
so start to notice something they attempted to go back
to the origin of the move okay so to the first absorption
and now there is this horizontal level that it's holding this is interesting we need to activate
also the speed of tape guys speed of tape it's a cheat code
you see what's happening here there is not much of activity it's pretty stable okay the last activity
was here here at the top failed they attempted to break we had a potential momentum trade but it
failed now the london section norik i just did some london session in the world trading cup and for reads
because he wanted to have some position management master class but uh london session is not giving me
the same momentum and edge that i have on new york there is a specific reason i don't trade it's not
that i don't want is that i don't have the same momentum and i can get stuck look at this week again
look at this week again
usually at uh after the opening i wait 30 minutes for the price to be stable so at four european time you
can see that it's central european time here and uh i consider this i consider this yeah it's not worth
it rick you take a lot of stop loss in the london because the market is really choppy
okay they went back to the same level what can you see from the speed of date that the sellers are
accelerating you see look at this momentum of the sellers would you consider this
a resulted effort or a failed auction again from the sellers is this is it getting more interesting
this is the best teaching i ever had it makes so much sense thank you
okay now i can consider also here to attempt okay along in momentum in my strategy because i can see
that all the momentum is building here i will only risk the profit i will put a really tight stop loss
okay and i will have a break even moment that is really close and also load the second one here okay
you see what i'm doing i'm trading the absorption of the sellers okay with a really tight stop loss okay
so the invalidation point is really close what am i doing here i'm betting on this case on the momentum
of the buyers is not a lot of money just it's a it's a scalp okay four thousand dollars on this one
with a really fast break even point okay now the condition for the auction are not the best and i
need also to monitor the chat so we cannot do hyper scalping but this is a relaxed trade where i am low in
size risking only the profit okay and i'm watching what i'm watching that what was before the speed of
tape of tape of the sellers now is the control and the speed of tape of the buyers this is something
interesting for me please don't don't execute guys it's not financial advice it's to show you also the
position are managed from a break-even point this is not a triple a setup we had better setup last session
if we have a triple a setup i will tell you this is how to show you in relaxed market condition
how the strategy unfold okay as you can see we are anticipating the squeeze what we had here double
absorption and we have a break-even point that it's really fast okay and the the order flow platform is
for fast execution guys the order flow platform is for fast execution it's important that you have it okay
because on usual platform you are ways lower on managing trades now what what i don't like what
you can see here what you can see here you see that the buyers are attempting attempting and they are
not having an easy time breaking through and i don't see participation of the buyers the speed of
tape is getting lower the sellers are ready to push on the way down okay the sellers are ready to push on
the way down on this one they are not having a follow-through on the auction now in position
really good even if they retrace i have a good standing ground here so i can do what i can protect
my position really fast when when we arrive here guys i cannot see the chat it's already difficult to
explain please watch the chart and try to understand what i'm doing also reading the question makes me
risk money for no reason i cannot even manage okay after we finish at least reach this break-even point
i will start to talk back with you what you can see on this absorption level i spoiler for you what i can
see this is a strong level from the sellers guys okay this is a strong labor they are not having an
easy way through this level it's not easy it's not easy to break now it's not stupid to consider that
if we don't break this level we go risk-free it's not stupid okay so if you see another attempt another
attempt you want to take out the risk of all the market you can do it okay so they are attempting again
watch how the market is doing on this one
let's see if they can break the speed of tape is not present
the buyers are presenting themselves okay perfect how much drawdown did we add on this position
how much candle how many candles of drawdown we had in this candle zero okay zero
i'm doing this live only for one reason because i want to show you that even when i'm watching a chat
and even when i don't have a triple a setup the method have an edge okay i am skin in the game i'm risking
real money without zero delay
look at this attempting the breakout attempting the auction speed of day presenting itself
they are loading they are continuing to load okay now the first point you need to accept that the
market can go back this is the reason of breakeven you need to be comfortable with the market snapping
back at you it's part of the game guys it's part of the game when you lose your attachment to profit
and you get close to the understanding of the process process and the acceptance
that you can have some day that are in consolidation you get a master
okay
now it seems that the auction is unfolding nicely seems that the auction is unfolding nicely
the speed of tape it's stable the imbalance they create here from a price action point of view
it's stable usually when they do this they come back to the beginning of the candle to spike down a little bit before reloading let's see
hold him back inside again the sellers are aggressive on this one guys it's not the best setup
not the best setup
i'm pretty sure
that this motherfucker
will come back to put their nose back inside the 26 070
people putting profit in the chat interaction of the sellers look at this look at this sellers are heavy
on this level they are happy to engage okay they are happy to engage what does it mean
that there is a wall here okay when this wall gets interesting this wall gets interesting in case the
buyers run this through okay in case the buyers run this through the wall gets interesting
so
one second guys i'm observing the interaction it's it's trust me it's crazy difficult to
manage trades reply to the chat doing analysis i'm
using 99 of my brain
wait a second now i come to you
i'm trying to give you the best education experience you have ever seen in your life but please be patient with the chat
the buyers are attempting to squeeze look at this look at this uh look at this uh look at this
interaction of the buyers
you see that they spike the top and the sellers reloaded this is a liquidity wall
this is a liquidity wall
this is a liquidity wall and buyers they are the sellers are protecting passively the buyers are
pushing on the level aggressively they are not letting the level go down they are not letting the
level go down and this is the best movement when you have an acceleration okay you have an acceleration
here i don't give to the market back my money covered covered
never give the money that you make back to the market never be smart be fast learn to manage
guys people cannot believe that i do this live to the point that on twitter they are saying no but
your account is demo because in their mind this is not possible
now we get probably a test here
to the balance level
touched is this white level okay now they reload again they try to break and i'm covered below this
level because if this level fail probably we go down let's see if the buyers reload enough to create
another breakout
no there is no delay guys there is no delay i'm doing this live there is no 15 second delay
and you can compare with your with your price action chart
you see they are attempting to break they are attempt and the buyers are absorbing okay
take a little bit more profit out of the market every 100 euros count every 100 euros count
we are risking our money we are doing sacrifice to make this money don't let other people take it
protect every hundred euros in your account
uh but i already make 8 000 make 8 200
still on the same level you see they are pushing now the sellers are pushing now the sellers are pushing
okay what we do we ask it out of the position at profit who cares
look at this they are trying they are trying to run through the buyer support
and the speed of tape of the sellers is still the dominant one you can see in this candle
the buyers are trying their best to protect it the buyers are really aggressive in protection
they try to reload horizontal level
not a lot of interaction this is a balance area let's take other money out of the market
guys at the end of the month all these 200 300 500 that you take out of the market in every single
position will account to 20 30 000 more per month
now the buyers are dry the auction it's it's not interactive they are closed inside a range we can
see a lot of absorption here i want to see some interaction of the speed of tape of the buyers
they are joining again the top of the range and you can start to see this huge compression
okay we have this protection level
of the buyers and this one of the sellers
yeah now i come back to you wait one second because i can think that i spike again back here
here before rejecting
uh there is enough fight here there is enough fight
if we go here i take other money out of the market
there is a huge absorption at this horizontal level huge absorption and this is a good sign
this is a good sign because when they break it they accelerate
guys we have the remote control
other 300 out of the market take every sense on the floor everything counts guys
speed of tape aggressive buyers
absorption at the top of the sellers
let's let's take our other 200
guys i'm doing this to show you how risk is managed in real time okay
i hope this is appreciated
you see that this level is creating them problem and breakouts
if you break the top recover another 500 in our pocket
you see that the auction is dry on top spike spike spike but rejection
loading back at the 98
level of the absorption of the buyers
test this level
you see how they rebound at the white area mark we take other money out of the market we are 3750
auction at the top
oh look at this absorption look at this absorption
crazy absorption of the sellers on this one take out okay
9 598 for the session look what we say this is the perfect management of the trade
look how much profit he would have take back from us if you don't manage the trade
now buyers are trying to protect but you see that the sellers are running through
okay now i can give time to the chat okay
now i want to understand did you understand
the position management look how much it was beautiful cluster of absorption here bias long
they stuck to the wall they get rejected we took a rocket from the beginning of the move
and we exit when the seller start to control there is no management method that come close to this one
no position management method
okay
this is not aaa setup because we didn't add an aggression also okay we had only absorption
but it's still amazing okay
we risk 1400 to make 3750 we enter here we had zero candle of drawdown
okay now as you can see i want to show you something because now if we want to make the
perfect lesson i want to show you that this method is letting you exit when the buyers are not having
still good results okay and you can see that here is not the case because the buyers got the buyers
protected them so probably we have a continuation but usually you see that when the price start to
give control to the seller so you have aggressive buy trades on the sell movement usually you think
you have a continuation and then the market bam okay so it's good to know when to take profit
if it's uh if it's um trend day a directional day the concept of premium and discount is not paying as
many cents
no no wait because now look i saying tonight it's on you to buy everyone pizza no tonight it's on you to buy
me pizza now i know it's not an advice and stuff but how many of you guys already repaid the course
of the charting life by trading one in chat i'm really curious about it we draw off prop firm or it's
only one week
mother send some money next month it's charged 5000 for three months next next quick future
oh we had also the perfect example you see it's flipping the auction
you see it's flipping
imagine how much profit the market would have taken back if you don't know how to manage properly
steven is like fratello i joined today and repaid it with this move look at this
okay now we have the perfect lesson i show you the management and i show you why
coming out of the position here means saving 30 40 percent of the position we took the top
and you can see that the speed of tape it's on the buy side and they are completely eaten up by sellers
it's amazing
yeah but it's not about making money copying the analysis it's about understanding what i do okay
we went out here
okay now let's go to see the best setup that we have i need to say thanks to andrea
one guy from the italian team and also to luca because they are helping me by putting in uh
framing the best setup and uh andrea helped me creating this it's amazing okay that i want to go
through now uh next week probably we'll go out and order flow uh course on youtube that explain how
to use profile framing how to use the main stuff to understand the auction because i want to save
a lot of people that are losing money by following fake educators and for fake educators i don't want to be
offensive on the industry i want just to let understand that we educators have a responsibility
okay and when we pretend that we have the secret sauce and we don't even trade ourselves okay because
maybe we joined the world trading cap multiple times and we only lost money and then we did live
trading and we only lost money maybe it's time to say look guys i said something fake i'm not a trader
and we'll be more honest okay that's the reason i'm doing a lot of free content on youtube now let's go
here because i want to let you understand how a triple a setup look okay a triple a setup looks like this
you have a directional day okay you have a directional day you are using your fixed profile
now you remember in the first lesson that we did we show that the big delta on the left side okay it's
a big sign of reversal so if we are taking this wing from point a to point b okay and if we need to think
what's the best demand as the best demand we take this cluster here do you agree with me yes or no
because you have the two main peak of delta this is aggression this is executed order this is what i
studied during the years to make the best level objectively identifiable by everyone okay perfect so
we have this area this is the first step of a triple a okay the second step of a triple a is how you see
when the market is going down and you remember the session of last week how many times we executed and
we watch this setup you remember this setup it's similar to what we did now so now we have our area
okay so we have our area we have our explosion it's clearly visible where there is an aggression of the
buyers and we can also use the fixed profile and when we go back we see from executed order the absorption
of the sellers okay after this you see that the sellers are having a strong effort so this means
that they are selling a lot of contracts and these contracts have no results because the passive buyers
are protecting the level so what does it mean that then when the market goes back reload on the passive
liquidity reload on the passive liquidity this is what i call a punch to the wall so now let's try to
understand what the market is telling you you are long in bias you are executing your trades from the two
most important level that you have for the cash session from executed order not for the vatican city
algorithm that they coded for the industry but for executed orders okay and when you go back
they are telling you okay they are telling you that here they executed the first time and now they are
loading okay so you have three pieces of information and this is the reason this one for me it's a triple
a setups okay is it clear for everyone guys i have the direction i have the delta level i have the absorption
okay and i have the passive liquidity wall that i see using this with this i don't think what i'm
explaining is difficult okay now let's say that you want lower risk to reward higher win rate okay if you
want let me check the chart because now rick is telling sending the chart now look at this this is what
happened also when i did live trading with treats are the buyers getting rewarded
is our exit point smart of course guys imagine if we are stubborn and we want to take our full take
profit and we stay in the position all this time because we want to take our profit can you imagine how
much this is stupid you know what you are saying to the market this is what you are saying i'm willing
to risk my 4000 profit to make sure 200 this is what you are doing when you don't go out when the market
is telling you the opposite you are doing an amazing inverse risk to reward
okay perfect now going back to this later we go back to charting let's say that you want to see
a lot of blue a lot of green in your trading platform okay i need to repeat every time i say
this is not financial advice this session are made for educational purpose okay i'm a professional trader
and i'm sharing with you my process this is not financial solid solicitation don't do it only open
with virtual account don't risk one cent okay now let's go back to what's interesting uh this absorption
here it's what it's telling us that we have a punch to the wall but you want to have a high win rate
trades and this is the reason the setup that we saw before it's aa it's not triple a why because
it means this or this okay so it means the market telling you that the buyers are aggressively
trade taking control and you know what's the cherry on top the cherry on top is when you have this
and you have also an absorption of the sellers look up how much is powerful this setup
luca is following me from the beginning studying closed in the room printing money
from years and years he's following me how much is powerful this luca
this one okay this one it's the moment that the market is telling you if you enter on the aggression
with a double confirmation of wall of direction of location and absorption guys if you manage to lose
money with this setup i really need to congratulate with you because i i cannot it's really difficult to
lose money on this setup okay because it's a fast risk-free setup it's a directional explosion setup and
it's not for me or for damien from ben from jason now i know that every one of us have a different
journey okay i want to tell you mine when i can oh amazing what's happening i met amazing the absorption
we are going long now we go back to chart this is a reload we will go long from this level okay we will
go long then we go and we have a different journey okay but i want to tell you something
in the process of trading you encounter multiple models multiple mentor multiple strategy okay my
mission here is to give you something that is not personal okay so my question to you is this one
after what you are studying here we already did more than six hours of lesson plus pdf that i loaded
plus setups plus position management you already got more than 20 hours of content okay considering
this week that we are doing now have you ever encounter a method where what you see is what i
see and what lucas see without studying for five years so that it's a plug and play method where you
see actual execution you don't need to put discretionality but it's a model that is based on actual data
yes i finish on this one we can go we can go back to the chart
now look at nasdaq okay look at nasdaq he decided to do in live timing exactly what i was telling you
this is nasdaq okay now you know what will be amazing if we mark the profile
look at this this is all the interaction where are the buyers more let's move the chart oh
if you are not blind you are capable of seeing that in all this auction the point of maximum
aggression of the buyers is this cluster okay this one in the majority so this blue level is the major
level can you give me one in chat this is not subjective guys this is not a subject it's for
for everyone like this okay look how they protect this reload
and you know from here
now probably what they do probably they come back
to say hi to this cluster
before continuing higher
here they go they are loading they are loading come back home
here
so
test is done okay the test on the area is done now you see interaction or absorption
you see interaction of absorption this is just price action
how do you mark this cluster it's just the last level that they
the buyers broke okay this was level one this is level two so this is where they usually test
okay this is where they usually test look how they are reloading
speed of tape is not significant let's see the cvd
see what the cvd is doing this is this is really important that you see when the market is unfolding
live you see this huge absorption the delta is printing red purple sorry candle they got completely
absorbed sellers got completely absorbed on the bottom tick crashed what does it mean that now
when you have aggression of the button oh today nasdaq it's amazing it's with a remote control
now when you see aggression of the buyers you will see less effort because it's the same effort but
more results look at this and now we should have participation of the buyers in an aggressive way so
big trades at the top okay so breaking out this level we should see again because remember that
buyers today are engaging at the top you should see again big trades okay
so breaking this auction with a strong movement that is also supported by
the speed of tape let's go on the speed of tape now
guys but what i need to tell you
look at this
you see that the sellers are still trying now if we go on the cvd i think they are absorbing
on the way up
okay you see that they also absorb the previous one so all this execution got absorbed by buyers
this is a reload sellers on the delta they are trying to absorb and buyers absorbing the move
it means that as soon as they get aggressive you see
it means that as soon as they get aggressive you see that this is the most difficult level to break
once it's done
they should they should
anyway this will be the atp yeah the
so from the level of the test or from let's make also worst level okay
this one i didn't execute it but let's make this candle that close with absorption
it's another 3.5 look at people making money
this guy made three thousand
guys there is one person of the group that had the courage to watch everything after he paid peanuts
and saying that the product is useless asking for refund one out of all the people one
it was ict
probably what an amazing banger guys if also this one goes
another amazing session now there is someone that executed all the setup that we saw in life that can
consider the count of risk to reward total are multiple i think we are well above 15
in three sessions
ah of course
i don't know if you saw but here there is also our favorite gap
i explained before sergio because it's a round number is the 26 100 and they are really powerful
the 26 100 the 26 200 the 26 300 the round levels hold a lot of power on the nasdaq
they hold a lot of power because it's where options are located
look at this look at this they are pushing and buyers are absorbing at the top we continue
we continue the auction this one is a little bit stupid target because it's really close
but anyway they are pushing aggressively at the top so there is a lot of interaction of the sellers
but the candle you you see that buyers are absorbing this movement they want to continue
now even if they retrace to reload still this is an information from order flow that is telling me
they are aggressive on the sell side while we are at the top range and the buyers are happily
absorbing all disorder guys you cannot see this from price action it's not visible from transaction
you cannot see if they go back here it's a reload level there is also a micro gap but it's really
difficult that they go here because you see as as soon as they try to go down i think the speed of
tape of tape of the buyers it's going to present really soon see if i can see
okay one second watching you read this live is priceless
you only cannot see it's not moving so fast the price no it's
you see it's not present the aggression of the buyers it's not here on the speed of tape probably
with this candle and also buyers at the top a good up and we go and we finish the session
yes exactly steven we high on the curve but this the buy pressure is visible
look at the people making money guys are you interested in what i say or you want to only
want to make money roy i'm happy for you that you are printing
and now fabio my head is full of so much value amazing guys
guys guys i want to do something
i want to select the best
best 20 10 to 20 traders i already have five please if you are already profitable stable you
are valuable to the community okay so text me inside the platform how it is going during your
journey from how much time you are consistent because you will be part of the battlefield that
i will open this week what is the battlefield a chat with the best traders around okay using my
method so you all use the same execution method and i will be present also when i have time i will
correct analysis i will help you and you have also the help of the community my goal here is
to build the best professional community in the space okay this is my goal to have the best professional
around and i really hope that people are willing to protect the value not reselling the information
pretending that it's their information because this will be really cheap from your side but that you
really contribute to give back to the community that gave you value okay now why you you see why i
mark the 26 100 you can see how much resistance we have when we go really close to the round numbers
this is a wall this is a wall
there are 101 111 contracts on 26 100 seeing from i know
but i know because i trade this asset from years guys you know what's the best advice i can give you
don't execute on three four assets trust me get good with one asset one can pay your bills can pay your
lifestyle one asset one i choose nasdaq because it's the love of my life and it's easy for me to
understand if you want to execute my method i can say that nasdaq is the best if you want to implement
what i teach you on other asset look at this gap look at this gap is in intra gap inside here this is
the reload phase if they close bullish here they shoot to 100. see this small gap on the white level
they are aggressively now they have a wall and they they are being absorbed here but they are still
pushing on the aggression side the buyers still it's dry from speed of tape so they are not loading
heavy contract fast let's see how they behave what is the meaning of this gap it's when you have a
big aggression now the speed of tape is saying to you they are not fast in getting aggressive but they
have a big aggression so usually usually this level you see they weak down they close and then
they continue this is what you usually see specifically if the candle close in the same
direction of the gap so you have a up gap with a green candle and then you you continue you see
another gap here you see it so now they rebalance you see what they shoot they are being absorbed here
because it's full of limit order there is a wall they had another gap here you cannot see if we close
close green they shoot another up move okay it's important the full close of the minutes or if
they get absorbed it's important the closure of the candle you go down okay let's see how it close
can you call them restriction what do you mean yeah the speed of tape is almost how fast or there are
being inputs you see that the previous gap it's holding the second gap up
and now they had a gap down here now they had a small gap down
small gap down there is a lot of fight on these levels
a lot a lot of fight look at people in the chat showing the zero drawdown entry and the exit at the
top beautiful crazy value brother was 3000 up before this session what i've learned from watching
the video you already paid three times for the value i've been applying your trend following model
to the brazilian index futures markets working really well i made 1000 in a day and 755 in a shop
look here look here you see on which level they are aggressive on the 26 100 they heated up all the
limit orders and now
yeah yeah it's pretty predictable when you understand what they are doing
guys there is some i always want to do something if there is someone from india i think my model can
be a money printer on the nifty because the nifty is really directional okay it's really directional so
i think on the nifty if there is any indian here you have an opportunity to use one of the best method
of order for that is the one that i explained on a really directional asset i think you can make even more
money than nasdaq i need to find the time to make a deep test on that one look at this absorption they
reload and absorbed reload and absorbed on this level exactly on the gap beautiful
still some sellers are absorbing but when they give up you continue the squeeze
of course fabio if we are mediocre now but someday in practice and experience we became great and
profitable can we join the battlefield of course guys i'm only choosing people that are at the level
that can help others and it's not to keep someone out it's to make sure that the information you get
are valuable it's like if i act as a filter okay because i want to give you people that already
made it that already are making one thousand two thousand three thousand per day they can help you
it's additional value this was not planned to be in the in the pack okay and i think i i saw look
at this guys look at this look at this reload on the on the gap now i know how much this is valuable
and i know how much money i made trading okay i showed this live they saw they see me some session
trust me when i created the pricing okay and i had a talk with the team and i say let's make one thousand
for till the end of last quarter they say to me i was crazy i can make 10 times more 50 000 more in
one session it's a ticket that is really low but i made this for one reason because if i managed to make
people profitable okay they will be able later to sustain okay if i go more high ticket and i can
make a small group of killers a small group of killers trader okay but in the beginning i wanted
everyone to be able to join okay with a ticket that it's okay for everyone let's be honest one thousand
dollars it's okay for everyone okay see the sellers are willing to absorb at the top
so the profile framing was long the profile framing was long and look at the 26 100 they break it
with a lot of aggression okay and they are reloading on it they are reloading okay now for today
we already close with a huge risk to reward okay huge we took two one break even and two amazing long
thanks fabio managed to pass my first only prop account in december now this month i'm already over
10 percent in profits also charles today 1 000 in profits i i know how much the model is valuable but i
will not think that after one week you have these results to be honest to be honest there is john maria
it's over 20 20 20 in profit 1000 on friday i will not think that the learning curve is so fast
and i have only another proof from this that live charting and seeing how i manage position and
everything that there is inside here it's more valuable than courses there is no way around it
this is the best way to learn is the best way
sellers are getting aggressive at the top but the buyers are like where do you think you are going
where do you think you are going here and it's crazy to see that the auction is dry like the speed of
tape is dead they are deciding what to do but we have interesting absorption you know what i'm
considering to use only the profit of today i'm considering a little bit to take a potential squeeze you know
i'm taking this into consideration
it's a really small stop loss
look at the level that we mark now if they break this level they want to go down
so the the potential momentum separate setup it's invalidated they want to retrace
i want to see the close of this candle what they do
because the you see how they managed to protect and see if the speed of tape is so huge long aggression
no speed of tape is stable
they protected at this level nine risk to reward on the day using us amazing guys it's crazy really crazy
crazy look at this guy alex and richard all take profit on the way up text me guys there is the chat text me
i put you as uh admin of the chat battlefield one for sure will be luca one will be me and then i i'm
searching for other eight people that can help other members of the chat this is nice
i'm inside
super small risk seven hundred dollars but if we manage to clean this level up
is to 115
also keeping it's not a bad idea so we are filled we are only risking 1000
we have super small risk
if they break this level doesn't make sense to continue to search for lungs because they want to go down
i will not put a take profit because if they do a squeeze they can pay out really good
you know what i like i like this absorption i like this absorption a lot i like this absorption a lot
if we manage to break this big i go immediately risk free
and we see what they do they add an aggression with a gap down
back to the level
let's see if this is the time that they break
what do you mean the pdf on the speed of tape it's not pdf it's an indicator
but the buyers are trying
look at the chat winning trades 81 percent
yeah there is a macro a micro gap on the downside this is not a good sign for my long trade
but still i'm in the action because my stop loss is
it's really irrelevant and i like this i like this absorption you see i managed to get the perfect
level for the long but now the buyers are getting absorbed now the sellers are strong the buyers attempt
but they are getting absorbed okay if they manage to clean this level we have a nice movement
back to the absorption level you see this dance
this is a dance and you need to learn how to do it
we are risking 0.5 r on this one not even one r
and they took us out on this one they took now now you know what it will be funny if they took us out and
now it's part of the game huh let's see how they behave anyway 81 is crazy if you are doing one to
one i can understand but if you are doing one two two one two three with 81 percent
it's crazy number arsenal oh they flip the auction you see look at this look at an ass look at the chat
an ass execution that he took this cue okay this is incredible send me in the chat because i put in the
in the battlefield preparation chat look at what anas published look at the profit average profit that
he make and the average stop loss this is incredible incredible
you see what they did in the breakout they managed to create another gap i don't know if it's visible
from the chat but they made a really visible gap what does it mean that the selling pressure on this
way it's so strong that they gap down okay so now the sellers you see this attempt i managed to take
the attempt to to break but it was not enough to go outside the auction okay what does it mean that
we go with a high probability to rebalance this area it is strange that the speed of tape is not
participating in this movement guys but it's me it's a bug or also you have zero participation in the
speed of tape here okay i was thinking it's a bug because they are getting really dry so the the
volatility surge it's finished some amazing trade we managed also to try to do the momentum squeeze
with 0.5 r so we have two one two three risk to reward six r minus 0.5 we have we are at four 5.5 r
amazing and i'm not even considering this one okay i'm considering the first two lungs and what we are
watching now is absorption one reload of the sellers and this absorption here is significant and we go back to
the first aggression level now i will not advise that you are interested in these movements because
there is no presence of aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers and for everyone that will be
here on the live of thursday so in two days expect two main things the first one is the official opening of
the chat so i will announce the work and we will see live how it works and i will choose people so text
me on this one the second one is that i will upload for you in the dedicated section this so you can go
through the execution and check if they respect this there are people publishing in the chat the results
they are having this is almost 20 to 30 trades with an amazing few of the long and now the auction is
dry i consider this a 10 out of 10 session from an educational perspective not from the money we
made because it's only 8 000 that is still for a lot of people it's a lot of money consider that the
maximum risk that we took today it's 1400 and have an amazing day have an amazing session if we if you do
the power hour and see you next time this week please trade safe don't get too much aggressive and trust me
the battlefield chat will be out of this world okay i'm sorry to see people that try to take advantage
so getting inside studying and then asking for refund because this is really unrespectful for the work
i'm doing but i know that stopping to do education for 0.1 of people that are really
insignificant from a statistical perspective and don't appreciate
is something that will make me really stupid if i decide to close so enjoy this and see you on thursday
so